earlier this week 49ers cornerback
richard sherman
telling it like it is as it comes to
jerry jones it's not pulling them like
it is the rest of the country he said in
reference to owners because if it was
then they'd speak jerry jones especially
has no problem speaking up
any other time about anything else but
when it's such a serious issue and he
could really make a huge impact on it
with just a few words his silence speaks
volumes clarence hill who
is shireen's former colleague at the
fort worth star telegram wrote a column
about it a lot of people are talking
about a lot of people are wondering
about it and shireen you've been around
jerry jones enough to know he is not at
a loss for words on anything on this
topic he is
and the longer it goes without him
saying anything it's it's just hard not
to wonder what's really going on here
and for me i think it's simple he
doesn't want to to say anything that
would further
exacerbate the problem that is looming
now between the president and the nfl
because i think jones was part of the
effort to broker a ceasefire a couple of
years ago
but that's all out the window now and i
really do think that it's time for all
owners to to talk and if you have a
history of talking it becomes even more
incumbent that you do and it becomes
even more conspicuous when you don't
yeah
he
jerry has never been a loss for words i
i think i can count i covered the
cowboys for 17 years and you know i
think i can count probably on two hands
the number of times after games that he
didn't talk he always talks
and the unfortunate part of of not being
able to go out to the facility over
these last three months has been not
being able to get jerry jones because
you know when you get him cornered
he's going to talk and he's going to say
a lot and and he hasn't even done his
radio show now in several weeks so he
has been silenced and unusually silenced
and and it's been curious about why he
is so quiet and i'm sure it's all these
issues but the cowboys have not released
a statement jerry hasn't talked um and
and i do think it's time for him it's
past time i mean let's just put it there
he should have done this
two weeks ago three weeks ago whatever
it was to put out a statement and say
something and he hasn't done that so yes
i
richard sherman's right his silence does
speak volumes and it's gonna get to a
point where he's gonna have to come out
and say something i think the pressure
is building on him having to do that and
it it's time it's time for him to talk
he's never been silent on anything
jerry step up and and say something and
and hopefully it's the right thing that
that his stance on the national anthem
has changed
you know and here's the reality it
applies in this context in any other
context where
the window is open to say something or
do something
if you don't take advantage of it when
the window's open it becomes harder to
do it it becomes more awkward when you
finally do it because now you're not
just dealing with the issue itself
you're dealing with why it took you so
long
to deal with the issue and it's only
going to get worse the longer that he
waits he's not going to be able to kick
this can all the way until week one of
the regular season and it's not like
anybody's going to be there to ask him
questions quite possibly then he's got
to do something sooner than later my
advice to him would be
do something now because with each
passing minute it is going to be harder
it is going to be more awkward more
strange when you finally do it you're
going to have to address why you've been
silent all of this time and
uh and and again he's he's just one of
the many owners who have
avoided some of the more delicate issues
here and that's what they pay the
commissioner to do in theory to be the
one who is the pin cushion for these
difficult issues but
this is the moment where all of those
old rules go out the window and there
has to be a human moment not a pr
designed moment i think that's part of
the problem here the the the pr advice
that would guide you through a normal
crisis
that doesn't work here this is a moment
to be a human being not a calculated
strategic business executive
who's saying the right thing at the
right time and striking the right tone
in order to get the right response
from the right people it's about being a
human and opening your heart and your
soul and letting those feelings
guide you and i i don't know that i look
i don't know i'd like to be a
billionaire to find out if billionaires
are capable of doing that sometimes i
wonder if they're too detached from
everyone else to really do that
mike let's let's go back to last friday
president trump made drew brees take a
stand he had to make a choice he had to
choose but
really between his job and in in the
national anthem and and he chose uh what
he chose and he spoke out against
president trump jerry jones and
president trump are tight we know that
they talk all the time we know that
jerry is backed into a corner now and
whether it's today
or monday or two weeks from now or a
month from now or however long it is at
some point jerry jones is going to have
to make a choice his players are
president trump he's going to have to
take a side there's no question about
that it's got to be done
he's not going to be left with a choice
and he's going to have to make that
choice and i'm guessing he's going to
side with his players it's it's a guess
but
to me he has to side with his players
in this fight
and and tick off trump which is what
he's going to do but i i think that's
what has to be done and i don't see any
middle ground he found the middle ground
a couple years ago we were talking about
the national anthem remember that i
think it was a monday night game with
the cardinals and they all took a knee
together before the game and that was
you know the way they worked that out
there is no solution that i see in this
he's going to have to make a choice here
and it's not just choosing between the
president and the cowboys players it's
the president along with
his supporters his
base the people who may make good on
that threat that i'm not going to follow
the cowboys anymore and i would just say
this to jerry look they're still
following the team even though you
haven't been to an nfc championship game
since 1995. they they have suffered
through
far worse than this moment when it comes
to shaking their faith in whether or not
they want to continue to be cowboys fans
i mean let's be real about it there's
still the cowboys are st i asked steven
jones about this a few weeks ago how in
the world are you still america's team
when you haven't been in the nfc
championship game in 25 years so that's
part of i think what jerry is concerned
about because he knows that the
president will keep pressing that button
if this fight continues and that there
will be people who are pressing that
button right along with him but they
need to not worry about it they need to
not care about it they need to not cower
to the threat to huff and puff because
at the end of the day they're not
blowing the house down all right the
players
have been speaking out on these issues
more than ever before prominent players
speaking out that makes the owners
silence even more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports